-Guys, the big story is
that today President Trump met
with Russian President
Vladimir Putin in Finland.
Trump was pretty nervous.
So which makes sense,
because most people are nervous
when meeting their boss.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They met one-on-one, and the
meeting lasted for two hours --
or about one hour and 58 minutes
longer than his meeting
with Stormy Daniels.
And just so you know --
Put it in perspective --
[ Laughter and applause ]
But it was the first time Trump
and Putin had met one-on-one
behind closed doors.
And this is very interesting,
Trump actually released a video
to describe how excited he was
to be alone with Putin.
Watch this.
-I think we're alone now.
There doesn't seem
to be anyone around.
And I think we're alone now.
The beating of our hearts is the
only sound.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, according to experts,
Trump and Putin had a lot
to negotiate in their meeting.
Trump says the
negotiations went great.
Putin now controls New York
and California.
And in exchange,
Trump got three magic beans.
So it's very, very --
[ As Trump ]
"Who knows what they do.
I don't know.
Embarrassing."
[ Normal voice ] Actually,
at the end of the meeting,
Trump and Putin didn't sign
any formal deal or agreement,
mainly because they both spent
the whole time trying
to make sure the other guy
wasn't Sacha Baron Cohen.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Trump ] "Are you real?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] But after their
time together, Putin did say
that the meeting went very well.
In fact, it went so well that
Putin said he might make Trump
President for
another four years.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Nice of him.
-He said that.
A lot of people
are talking about this.
[ Laughter ]
Trump and Putin also held
a press conference
where Trump actually defended
Putin and seemed to side
with Russia over his own
intelligence agencies.
Check out what
he said about 2016.
-All I can do is ask the
question.
My people came to me.
Dan Coats came to me
and some others.
They said, they think it's
Russia.
I have President Putin.
He just said it's not Russia.
I will say this, I don't see
any reason why it would be.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, sure, if Putin told you,
it must be true.
It's like, [ As Trump ]
"Good enough for me.
My people --"
[ Normal voice ] What?
[ Applause ]
But after the press conference,
CNN, MSNBC, and even Fox News
slammed Trump
for his performance.
Trump said he shouldn't jump
to any conclusions until we hear
what Cartoon Network has to say.
Then we know it's bad.
[ Applause ]
But, it wasn't all business
at the meeting.
When he first sat down
with Putin, Trump talked about
the World Cup.
He sounded like a real expert.
Listen to this.
[ Camera shutters clicking ]
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
"Soccer -- It's like foosball,
but with actual people.
Just with actual people."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
Then he said, [ As Trump ]
"And American football
is the one where I yell at all
the players on Twitter.
That's what we call
it in America."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] At the end
of their press conference,
Putin actually gave Trump
a soccer ball.
Take a look at what Trump did
with it, watch this.
-Speaking of the football,
actually.
-[ Speaking Russian]
-Mr. President, I'll give
this ball to you,
and now the ball is
in your court.
-[ Speaking Russian ]
-That's very nice.
In fact, Melania, here you go.
[ Laughter ]
-That's also how he gave Melania
her engagement ring.
[ As Trump ] "Here,
just pick it up.
Take it out, take it out."
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Putin was like,
[ As Putin ] "Be careful.
There's expensive recording
device inside soccer ball.
So speak into
the little nozzle when you --"
[ Light laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Speaking
of soccer, this weekend,
France won the World Cup
and they were led by
a 19-year-old prodigy
named Kylian Mbappe, yep.
After the game,
Mbappe said winning
the World Cup totally makes up
for being named after
a Hanson song.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Mmm-bop, mmm-ma,
mmm-ma, mmm-bop ♪
♪ Mmm-bop, mmm ♪
I know you feel it.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and before he met Putin,
Trump was in the U.K.
where he met Queen Elizabeth.
Did you see that?
It got off to a bumpy start
when the first thing Trump told
the Queen was that
he knows all the words
to "Bohemian Rhapsody."
He's like, [ As Trump ]
"Can you do the fandango?
I do fandango. Mbappe."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] You see this?
When Trump met with the Queen,
they went to view
the Royal Guards.
And he got a little confused
about where to position himself.
Check this out.
[ Band playing ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness.
-Oh, come on!
What?
-Trump walks like every single
tourist in Times Square.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Trump ] "There's a lot
of M&Ms in that store.
Take a picture.
That's a lot of M&Ms."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] All right.
Some good news here --
the 12 boys who were rescued
from a cave in Thailand
last week are
about to be released.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're about to be released
from the hospital.
They said the first thing
they want to eat is KFC.
[ Light laughter ]
Then their doctor is
like, "Dear God,
haven't your bodies
been through enough?
I mean, good, please.
What are you doing?"
And finally, I heard that you
can now buy high-heeled Crocs
on Amazon.
[ Light laughter ]
Take a look at these.
Yep.
They're great for when you want
say, "I have somewhere to go
and nowhere to go
at the same time."
You guys, we have
a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!